in this lesson we'll look at the
reaction mechanisms of glycolysis
focusing on the first five reactions in
the energy investment phase where atp is
consumed our journey through glycolysis
begins with the enzyme hexokinase
which catalyzes the conversion of
glucose to glucose 6-phosphate
adding a phosphate group to this c6
hydroxyl here
this reaction requires atp and produces
adp as a product in biochemical
mechanisms we often show very
abbreviated acids and bases we're not
sure if it's an amino acid side chain or
another acid doing a protonation or
deprotonation and so we might show
something like the deprotonation of this
alcohol with a very generic base
i have b representing a base here and
i'm showing a pair of electrons to do
our deprotonation
for the arrow pushing first the
electrons on the base grab the proton
so our arrow starts on this lone pair
and points to the hydrogen it
deprotonates
in deprotonations we always show a
second arrow showing where this bond
ends up
and in this case it'll become a lone
pair on oxygen
overall this deprotonation will give us
products that look like this
we have an alkoxide and the base has
grabbed the proton
notice we're not keeping track of any
charge on the base if it was neutral and
grabbed a proton it would have a
positive charge but when we're
representing this in a simplified way we
don't necessarily need to keep track of
the charges on our generic base but the
reaction mechanism of hexokinase has
been well studied so we can do a little
bit better than this in this reaction
the base is the side chain of the amino
acid aspartate
here's aspartate and we can show one of
the lone pairs on the negatively charged
carboxylate doing the deprotonation
this is an abbreviation for atp
we're showing amp as our abbreviation so
we have adenosine monophosphate over
here so there's already one phosphate
incorporated into this abbreviation
here's diphosphate triphosphate and this
abbreviation just allows us to show the
important pieces for the reaction
mechanism
atp binds to hexokinase chelated with a
magnesium ion
here's our magnesium and it'll interact
with two of these negative charges
this shields the negative charges a bit
and allows for attack to occur
for our mechanism the aspartate
deprotonates the c6 hydroxyl hydrogen
instead of showing these electrons
becoming a lone pair on oxygen as we did
in this general mechanism we'll show
these doing the attack at phosphorus
and finally to show this bond breaking
we'll add an arrow putting a lone pair
onto the oxygen of what will be adp
note with phosphorus it's not like a
carbonyl so we don't have to show the
electrons pushing up onto oxygen
phosphorus is large it has d orbitals
and so we can just show this attack
breaking this bond
for our enzyme classification this is a
transferase
we're transferring this phosphate group
from atp
onto glucose
6-phosphate and this reaction
substitutes the hydrogen on the c6oh
with a phosphate
therefore the reaction type is
nucleophilic substitution
next up is an isomerization reaction
catalyzed by glucose 6-phosphate
isomerase the reaction interconverts
glucose 6-phosphate and fructose
6-phosphate and at first it looks pretty
complicated because our ring size is
changing
but the ring size only changes because
we're going from an aldose to a ketose
so let's open up the carbohydrate ring
of glucose 6-phosphate to see how this
reaction occurs
to open the ring this hydrogen will be
deprotonated
these electrons will form the double
bond of this aldehyde
and when this bond breaks open it needs
to grab a proton from an amino acid
residue we'll show the base with our
generic abbreviation
but the amino acid that donates the
proton to open the ring is typically
lysine
to show our arrow pushing first our base
deprotonates
now we'll use these electrons to form
the aldehyde
and we'll show this bond breaking
grabbing a proton from lysine as the
ring opens
and don't forget to give that lysine a
lone pair we always need to show this
bond breaking with an arrow for good
measure let's number our carbons to keep
track of them
numbering on the ring we start here
and go around and numbering on the
fissure projection we start at the top
notice our double bond is forming to
carbon 1.
in
fructose-6-phosphate carbon-1 is right
here
we want to convert this to a ch2oh
and the way we're going to do that is
deprotonate here and make an enol
the basic amino acid side chain that
deprotonates the carbon 2 hydrogen is a
glutamate and we'll show a generic acid
donating a proton to our carbonyl to
form the enolate
we deprotonate this hydrogen that's
alpha to the carbonyl
using this side chain we'll add some
lone pairs to show the deprotonation and
the electrons from this carbon-hydrogen
bond push in to form the double bond of
the enol and this carbonyl is going to
break and grab this proton this forms an
intermediate called an in diol
here is our in diol an alkene now
between these two carbons and two oh
groups directly attached
i'll sneak a little bond between my o
and h to show this next bit of arrow
pushing
a basic amino acid residue can grab this
hydrogen
pushing the o-h bond in to make our
ketone
these electrons will push up
and the now protonated glutamate residue
can donate a proton on this end here's
our generic basic amino acid residue and
we'll position our protonated glutamate
near the top this time
start on the basic amino acid to show
the deprotonation push the electrons in
the o-h bond to form the ketone the
double bond will grab the proton from
glutamic acid and don't forget to show
these electrons becoming a lone pair on
oxygen this arrow pushing has produced
this compound which i just redrew the
carbonyl on the left hand side so we can
show the ring closure the carbohydrate
is now a ketose we've just moved the
carbonyl one group over
by creating an in diol and then
deprotonating in a different spot to
show our ring closure the lysine which
is deprotonated from this first ring
opening step attacks using its lone pair
the electrons from this o-h bond will
break the carbonyl and to show this bond
breaking we'll use a generic acid the
electrons in the carbonyl grab hydrogen
and we show these electrons going to our
base
this reaction is an isomerization that
moves the carbonyl
and therefore our enzyme is classified
as an isomerase
the reactions involved are enolization
to form the endiol and then a
re-protonation
so let's call a reaction type
enolization very common with carbonyl
chemistry
finally notice i sometimes use a circled
p to represent the phosphate group
instead of drawing all that out and i'll
continue to use that throughout this
video
the third step of glycolysis is the
conversion of fructose 6-phosphate to
fructose-1-6-bis-phosphate by the enzyme
phosphofructokinase
we're using atp and producing adp over
the course of the reaction
the enzyme name contains kinase just
like hexokinase which catalyzed the
first reaction of glycolysis
one very interesting aspect to this
reaction is that we're starting with the
alpha form of fructose 6-phosphate this
o-h group and the c-6 substituent are
away from each other on opposite sides
however in the product this o-h group is
on the same side of the ring as this c6
group
the product is beta this means the
carbohydrate has to undergo muta
rotation
now this might happen before or after
the phosphate group is introduced here
but let's just quickly show how the ring
can open and close using a generic acid
and base
the basal grab the proton kick these
electrons in to make the double bond and
we'll protonate this oxygen using our
generic acid now i've put an r group
here this could be the oh or it may
already be the phosphate when we undergo
this equilibration either way we have
the open form of the carbohydrate and we
can just reverse the reaction to close
the ring the carbonyl gets attacked from
the other side this time
which pushes this group down below the
plane of the ring and that gives the
beta anomer
aside from the mutorotation
the mechanism is identical to hexokinase
a base deprotonates this hydrogen and we
attack atp again we're transferring the
phosphate from atp producing adp and our
enzyme is a transferase the reaction
substitutes a hydrogen for a phosphate
therefore the reaction type is
nucleophilic substitution
each of the steps of glycolysis that
we've seen so far have resulted in a
more symmetrical molecule
notice we now have a ch2
on each end and it's bonded to a
phosphate the next step will involve
cleaving this six carbon carbohydrate
into two three carbon products
i have an entire video detailing the
mechanism of aldolase so we will only
cover this briefly here and try to
understand the logic of the cleavage
now back in step 2 of glycolysis we
formed enolates we formed an indial
intermediate
and we saw that the proton that is alpha
to the carbonyl gets deprotonated these
electrons push in to form an enolate
okay a similar thing is happening here
but instead of deprotonating we're going
to cleave a carbon-carbon bond so
instead of using this bond here from the
ch
instead take the alpha carbon
and think about
the next carbon it's bonded to breaking
let's represent that cleavage by showing
an arrow
so it'll be the electrons from this
carbon carbon bond pushing in
and now we can't make five bonds to this
carbon here
so we're going to have to break the
carbonyl shown like this this would show
these electrons becoming a negative
charge on the oxygen but let's just grab
a proton along the way all right well
carbon-carbon bond cleavage isn't easy
there's going to be some other factors
that help this along
now one of the factors is that in this
molecule we have an oxygen here and this
has two lone pairs
let's push one of those lone pairs to
assist the breaking of this bond adding
on our lone pairs and now showing the
arrow pushing and finally let's just
show a generic base removing this proton
so this process will result in cleavage
of this bond highlighted here in purple
and let's draw what we get so here's our
new hydroxyl the new double bond
and let's draw what we get from the
bottom half remember we're deprotonating
and forming a double bond here
now we can see we've already made a
molecule of glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
so we get one of our products directly
from this type of cleavage
but here we have an enol
and as we
saw before enols can tautomerize to
ketones or aldehydes and typically the
ketone or aldehyde form
is more stable
so basically in this tautomerization
we're going to see movement of a double
bond and a proton we can show this
transformation using some generic acids
and bases again
and our arrow pushing will look like
this
the base will deprotonate these
electrons can push in to form the
carbonyl
and this double bond can break and
become protonated
and here are the arrows to show our
tautomerization
in reality
a lysine residue reacts with this open
chain form of the carbohydrate
amines like lysine react with ketones to
form immunes or here an iminium ion
now this positively charged nitrogen is
even better at accepting the electrons
during this bond cleavage
and i'll refer you to my aldolase video
for that complete mechanism this enzyme
is breaking something into two
it's classified as a liase there are
quite a few different reactions going on
here
first the formation of this iminium ion
is a nucleophilic addition to a carbonyl
this step
is a retroaldol reaction so this is the
reverse of one of our carbonyl
condensation reactions
following the cleavage step using the
iminium
we're going to have
dihydroxyacetone phosphate still bound
to the enzyme so there will be a final
hydrolysis step
to liberate dhap from the enzyme
now after step 5 of glycolysis
the reactions will be identical for the
three carbon sugars
therefore we need to isomerize one of
the products from the previous reaction
so dhap gets converted to gap
the mechanism is similar to step two
dhap will be enolized to form an endiol
which reacts to form gap
the basic amino acid residue that's
going to deprotonate this hydrogen is
histidine
and the amino acid side chain that will
donate a proton to protonate this
carbonyl is glutamic acid the protonated
form of glutamate
since we've already seen a similar
mechanism see if you can pause the video
and try the arrow pushing to form the
in-dial on your own
using this lone pair histidine
deprotonates alpha to the carbonyl these
electrons will push in to form the
double bond which means this carbonyl
will need to break and when it breaks
it'll grab the proton from glutamic acid
let's draw our indial intermediate and
let's draw our amino acids in the
protonation state that they'll be in
after this step here's our deprotonated
glutamate and protonated histidine our
target is an aldehyde
so this glutamate can deprotonate this
proton i've tried to sneak in the oh
bond here which will push in
and then we'll break our double bond
accepting the proton from histidine the
arrow pushing looks like this
this represents an isomerization
of a ketone to an aldehyde therefore the
enzyme is an isomerase the reaction
involves enolization
followed by reprotonation of the in diol
to give the isomer